[Music]
my
hey there i'm now surprise and welcome
to a powerful new episode of rt
essentials dare i say that as a society
we love our superheroes i mean those box
office numbers don't lie friends just
look at films like avengers end game
which earned almost three billion
dollars and spider-man no way home which
took down avatar by becoming the third
highest grossing domestic release in
history but how does that translate to
the small screen specifically streamers
and networks looking to cash in on that
ubiquitous desire to watch the good
fight the evil and ultimately save or
not save the universe well i'd say it
translates pretty well in what many
consider to be the golden age of
television superhero series reign
supreme and i mean how could they not
when a series contains most of the
desirable elements of a film only
there's more of everything so my peeps
let's take a closer look at some of
these top contenders airing in a living
room near you these are our selections
for live action superhero tv shows
the flash
record this you have one minute flash
after that someone dies every 60 seconds
until you surrender what's mine i have
to stop him wait wait barry what look i
know you want to do this but you don't
have a lot of speed okay flying in first
is the flash a drama series based on
characters from dc comics now this
incarnation details the origin story of
barry allen who first appeared in the
comic anthology showcase back in 1956.
allen's journey to the flash began at
age 11 when his mother died in a freak
accident and his father was wrongly
convicted of her murder this inspired
him to become a crime scene investigator
dedicated to learning the truth about
his mother's death by following up on
every new scientific advancement and
urban legend when his latest obsession a
particle accelerator explodes it causes
a freak storm and allen is struck by
lightning nine months later he awakes
from a coma with the power of super
speed but soon learns that others have
gained similar powers and are using them
for evil allen's new mission is to
protect the innocent at all costs while
not losing sight of the older mystery
that still haunts him allen's character
was a reinvention of the original flash
jay garrick but for this series there is
a point in a later season where garrick
and alan actually coexist which plays
into the multiverse theory but i'll
spare you of any serious spoilers
they cross streams
now the flash was developed by greg
berlanti who just got his star on the
hollywood walk of fame andrew kreisberg
and jeff johns and it stars grant gustin
candice patton and danielle panabaker
now the series premiered in october 2014
on the cw network where it has remained
for eight seasons and
162 episodes rolling stone wrote that
quote like arrow this series nails the
feel of a vintage comic book without
being cheesy or cheap and the la times
called the show a quote effervescent and
super engaging addition to television's
increasingly grim comic book wars the
flash has been renewed for a ninth
season set to air in october of this
year and if only we could flash forward
to that legion
i was there
yes
you were the man in the car at the
hospital okay so i'm clear you're saying
after you entered the body of a woman
and escaped from a mental hospital where
all the patients had magically been
sealed inside of their rooms you think
you saw me getting out of a car legion
was created by noah hawley the man
behind the popular crime drama fargo now
holly has been interested in creating a
superhero show for some time and settled
on marvel's david haller aka legion
because of the character's mental
illness and the potential to depict and
deconstruct his unique mindset now in
the series hauler is diagnosed with
schizophrenia and gets shuffled from one
psychiatric institution to the next in
his early 30s he falls in love with a
troubled fellow patient named sid and
after a startling encounter with her he
must confront the shocking possibility
that the voices and visions in his head
might actually be real now with the help
of sid and a team of powerful
specialists david unlocks a startling
truth that he's been tormented his
entire life by an evil parasite with
unimaginable power now hollers played by
dan stevens a role that required the
skillful balancing of many personalities
stevens is nuanced in his portrayal at
times compassionate and optimistic and
other times openly battling the inner
demons that inhabit his character's
broken psyche
daddy
see you
now it's fair to say that no superhero
series has ever addressed the issues of
mental health so delicately and with
such impact at least until moon night
legion premiered on fx in february of
2017 where it ran for three seasons and
27 episodes reviews remained positive
throughout the entire run of the show
with the guardian writing that quote as
superhero tv reaches critical mass holly
has helped the genre take a necessary
evolutionary leap mutating it into
something refreshingly sophisticated and
artful though fans and critics were
unpleasantly surprised by the show's
cancellation holly stated that a
three-season arc was what he had planned
for legion from the very beginning
adding that he quote thinks endings are
what gives stories meanings and in a
world where superhero stories seem to go
on like literally forever there's
something poetic about legion's short
lifespan
marvel's jessica jones
come on
you can't hold back forever it's not you
count it out
this is the hold you used to kill nathan
melissa rosenberg created marvel's
jessica jones which premiered on netflix
in november of 2015. it chronicles the
life of one of marvel's darkest and most
mysterious characters you guessed it
jessica jones what gave it away when a
tragedy puts an end to jessica's
short-lived superhero career she settles
in new york city and opens alias
investigations her own detective agency
now despite wanting to do good jessica
suffers from post-traumatic stress
disorder and when she isn't focused on
saving the world she struggles with the
not so basics of being human don't we
all kristin ritter stars in the lead
role a character she herself has
described as very rough around the edges
and dry and sarcastic but at her core a
good person rosenberg started developing
jessica jones back in 2010 collaborating
with marvel television and planning to
air a first season in 2011 on abc but
unfortunately the network actually ended
up passing on the series at the time
citing creative differences and a desire
to make a show that featured jones is
more of a side character after years of
further development and a page one
do-over rosenberg was able to finally
make the show that she had envisioned
produced by marvel television abc
studios and her own company tall girls
productions that makes me feel really
short
the series ran for a total of three
seasons 39 episodes and received
numerous accolades including a peabody
award a hugo award and a prime time
creative arts emmy additionally it
received universal praise with sight and
sound writing that the show quote has
proved to be a game changer when it
comes to superheroes anti-heroes and
survivor narratives and quote the rest
of the industry will need to up its game
accordingly marvel's jessica jones was
cancelled sadly in 2019 due to high
production costs and insufficient
viewership numbers which is a total
bummer but all episodes are currently
streaming on disney plus so that's a
plus the falcon and the winter soldier
[Music]
[Music]
taking place after the events of
avengers end game the falcon and the
winter soldier is a mini-series that
premiered on disney plus in march of
2021. it was the second television
series in phase four of the marvel
cinematic universe and it features the
characters sam wilson aka falcon and
bucky barnes aka the winter soldier now
the mismatch duo team up for a global
adventure one that will test their
survival skills as well as their
patients anthony mackie stars as falcon
a role that he wasn't so sure about
portraying in this format when he first
got the call from executives at marvel
studios he figured that he was either
getting the best news of his life or
getting fired but the last thing he
expected was for marvel to say hey we're
gonna do a tv show mackie was fearful of
the difficulties that could arise when
translating the marvel brand to tv but
he accepted the role and brought an
unrivaled depth and emotion to the
television version of the character
come on
now creator malcolm spellman was one of
several writers who were asked to pitch
a series that focused on these two
characters executive producer and marvel
president kevin feige believe that the
mcu films hadn't explored falcon and the
winter soldier enough especially after
their dynamic in the captain america
movies received such a positive audience
response now the falcon and winter
soldier ran for six episodes and was met
with a positive critical reception the
atlantic wrote that the show's quote
commitment to the overarching theme of
american heroes and the danger of
exceptionalism has been unwavering
additionally the series was nominated
for five emmys including outstanding
special visual effects and outstanding
stunt coordination
dc's legends of tomorrow
that's our move they stole our move
enjoy your free will legends
legends of tomorrow premiered on the cw
joining the spectacular superhero
company of arrow and the flash now the
series follows the time traveling rip
hunter who after seeing what doom the
future holds brings together a ragtag
team of divergent talent with a common
goal preventing super villains from
destroying time itself no big deal now
the ensemble cast includes victor garber
brandon ruth katie lotz and many others
back in 2015 co-creator greg berlanti
stated that there were quote preliminary
talks about a superhero team-up show on
the cw featuring characters from both
arrow and the flash well i recognize
your influence
i show this armor fall
i want to test that reincarnation you
keep going on about oh hey great we
might need firestorm in
here try me again i don't need the old
man to make you regret it bruh and i
thought the ship was a mess when i got
there now the potential for crossovers
and dc universe expansion was massive
and by the end of 2015 the cw gave the
project a straight to series order now
since the show's premiere in january of
2016 each of the seven seasons have
become more unpredictable and exciting
and having a premise that revolves
around time traveling has allowed for
endless possibilities especially when it
comes to characters and scenarios in one
episode a young barack obama finds
himself in the crosshairs of the super
villain gorilla grodd i mean yes you
heard that right but anyways the point
is is that the show is always wild
legends of tomorrow has received several
saturn and teen choice award nominations
and has been praised for its quote fun
character dynamics fancy effects comic
book nostalgia and adventurous plots did
i mention there's an episode where
barack obama gets attacked by a giant
gorilla i think i did
hawkeye
jonathan igla created and produced
hawkeye a disney plus series that
similar to the falcon and the winter
soldier takes place after the event of
avengers end game it features the
characters clint barton aka hawkeye and
kate bishop a aka also also known as
hawkeye now i know it's somewhat
confusing if you haven't seen the show
but just to clarify the two aren't
related by blood but they both pick up
the hawkeye moniker at some point in
their lives now clint is more of a
friend and mentor to the younger kate
though their relationship is a bit more
complex in the comic book versions
jeremy renner and haley seinfeld co-star
in the lead roles with rice thomas and
bert and birdie directing now the series
is set in new york city during the
holiday season my favorite where barton
is focused on spending christmas with
his family after having lost them during
the blip
go let's go come on come on
[Applause]
how many we got
get in front of them get in front of
them
barton's family-oriented arc represents
a shift in power and responsibility when
it comes to being hawkeye now the first
two episodes are way more focused on
bishop's journey and her eagerness to
utilize her archery and martial arts
skills in the name of fighting evil it
plays like a passing of the torch from
master to apprentice the show is part of
phase four of the mcu and premiered in
november of 2021 running for a total of
six episodes the independent called
hawkeye quote a perfectly serviceable
action romp and the new york times
poignantly summarized the central
character dynamics stating that quote
steinfeld and renner are good foils for
each other as bishop pushes barton to
relax and he tends to hurt like a fussy
aunt
peacemaker
[Music]
[Music]
next up is peacemaker this show is a
james gunn creation based on characters
from dc comics it premiered on hbo max
in january of 2022 and is the first
series in the dc extended universe now
set just after the events of the suicide
squad the series follows christopher
smith aka peacemaker a man who fights
for peace at any cost no matter how many
people he has to kill to get it now
peacemaker first appeared in the
charlton comics issue fight in five back
in 1966. many of charlton comic's
superhero characters including this one
were later acquired by dc and
incorporated into their main superhero
line gunn began writing this spin-off
series while completing work on the
suicide squad something that he admitted
he wanted to do quote just for fun while
contemplating various platforms that
could host the show hbo max proved to be
the best option mostly because they were
a relatively new streaming service and
they'd be willing to give gun the budget
that he wanted any questions
uh yeah kid with the sad eyes
you said the black heart ruby weighed 30
pounds yes
and kite man was riding a kite
that's right wouldn't he have crashed
anyway due to gravity
now in september of 2020 hbo max ordered
peacemaker straight to series with gunn
writing all eight episodes of the first
season and directing five of them john
cena reprised the lead role and daniel
brooks co-stars as leota adebayo
peacemaker has received rave reviews and
very strong viewership numbers
consequence wrote that thanks to the
strength of the ensemble along with some
of the wildest action sequences seen in
recent memory the series does deliver a
lot of joy along with the continued
reminder that guns work as a storyteller
continues to get better and better a
second season has been ordered which
gunn is set to write and direct all
episodes
loki
[Music]
[Music]
the god of mischief brings all his
trickery to disney plus in the series
loki created by michael waldron now
taking place after the events of endgame
loki steps out of his brother's shadow
to embark on an adventure traveling
through time to keep his own existence
from being erased and ultimately
stopping a much greater threat with gugu
and bathura and one meme musaku
co-starring loki is the third television
series in phase four the mcu and
introduces the time variance authority
or tva an organization tasked with
monitoring the many timelines of the
multiverse you know it's a hard job and
it's about time someone did that i mean
things have really been getting out of
hand with all these timelines and
universes someone had to say it i'm
sorry who's us
last chance variant
it's been a very long day
and i think i've had my fill of idiots
in armoured suits telling me what to do
so if you don't mind this is actually
your last chance
now get out of my way waldron felt that
having the tva as a central component of
the show would actually be fun because
it made the miracle of time travel more
soulless and bureaucratic additionally
waldron felt that it was important to
hash out the details of how time travel
works at the tva in order for the
audience to easily grasp the concept but
on a deeper level the tva actually
helped loki to confront who he is and
who he's meant to be season one
premiered in june of 2021 and consisted
of six episodes and the series has been
praised for its visuals performances and
musical score the guardian wrote that
loki quote leans more enthusiastically
into the time-hopping adventure aspect
as it surely must and that viewers will
begin to have almost as good a time as
hiddleston and wilson clearly are that's
owen wilson they're talking about just
to clarify
the boys
no that's true
i got excited i'm sorry i'm sure you are
you know the drill he shot at us first
girl
this next series asks a very important
question what happens when instead of
fighting for the good of humanity
superheroes go rogue and start abusing
their powers in the boys an eponymous
team of vigilantes head out on a heroic
quest to take down a multi-billion
dollar conglomerate that manages
superheroes and covers up their dirty
secrets now the boys fight to expose the
seven a powerful group of shallow
celebrity figures who commit horrendous
crimes in secret now the seven were
founded by and worked for vot
international a company just oozing with
evil though somehow the general public
doesn't seem to have any awareness of
that evil just wanted to point that out
now the boys was developed by eric
kripke who rose to prominence as the
creator of the wildly popular cw drama
supernatural which aired for 15 seasons
i don't know he was just some uber
driver okay give me some
uber
based the boys on the comic book of the
same name which was originally published
by dc comics under their wild storm
imprint before eventually moving to
dynamite entertainment now as far back
as 2008 a film adaptation of the boys
comic series had been discussed with
columbia and paramount pictures
interested and it wasn't until 2016 that
krupke began developing the boys as a
series set for release on cinemax
eventually amazon prime video signed on
and the first season premiered in july
of 2019. the boys was nominated for
numerous awards including an emmy for
outstanding sound editing and
additionally the show received unanimous
critical praise with indy wire writing
that it quote gets so many parts right
like the skilled stunt work and expertly
staged action scenes other critics also
mentioned the humor storylines and
performances from that impressive
ensemble cast
wandavision
and you're definitely not my friend
and an outsider
and right now you are trespassing here
and i want you
to leave
last but certainly not least is wanda
vision a mini series created by jack
schaefer for disney plus the show is
based on the marvel comics characters
wanda maximoff aka scarlet witch and
vision aka
well i think actually he's only called
vision he's kind of like sting anyways
it follows wanda and vision who live
idealized suburban lives but soon start
to suspect that everything is not as it
seems one division takes place after you
guessed it avengers end game now
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany
reprised their roles from the film
series with matt shakman directing and
co-producing
fun fact shackman also directed an
episode of the boys i mean that guy
knows the superheroes the series
premiered in january of 2021 the
beginning of phase four the mcu and it
was universally adored and received
numerous accolades nominations including
wait for it 23 emmy award nods taking
home three not too shabby the atlantic
wrote that quote she's not the first
superhero to be affected acutely by
emotional pain yet for an mcu project
the choice to focus on wanda's inner
life is revolutionary one might even
call it wanda visionary okay i added
that last part and there you have it our
top picks for live action superhero tv
shows as always we couldn't include
every series that fits into this
category but there are plenty more
episodes of rt essentials coming at you
soon so i'm sure we'll get there thank
you again so much for tuning in i'm naz
perez and always remember with a great
series comes great responsibility so
start streaming bye
[Music]
you